When I became
president, I thought
about how we lacked
convening spaces
for the university as a whole
and places where people could
come together, and
exchange ideas, and learn
from one another, as they should
in a residential university
setting.
And as I appointed a task
force on common spaces,
the financial crisis emerged
almost at the same time.
And so some of the
grandiose designs
that the task force
was envisioning
were somewhat scaled down.
And we began to
think, what could we
do right away that could make
a difference without having
to have a huge
investment of resources?
And so the task force
made a recommendation
that I think has changed
Harvard fundamentally.
They pointed out that
in old Harvard Yard,
people raced through.
They always felt they ought
to be going somewhere.
And they ought to look like they
needed to be going somewhere
and had something of
importance to accomplish rather
than to linger, or
have a conversation,
or find a place in
which to interact.
And in fact, there were
no benches or places
to sit in Harvard Yard.
And so the task force
recommended that we
install chairs in Harvard Yard.
They're chairs of
the sort that you
find in the garden of
the Tuileries in Paris,
though we have them in
multi-colors rather than just
pale green.
And so the chairs appeared.
And I've had such a wonderful
time over the last decade or so
since they did appear
watching how people use them.
They pull them together.
They put their feet on one and
their laptops on their knees.
They bring their babies and
rock them in their strollers
next to the little grouping of
chairs where the mothers are
having a conversation.
Students sit down.
And someone just comes up
and sits down next to them,
and a new friendship is born.
So it's changed the
attitude, I think,
of people towards the Yard.
Because it makes
possible the opportunity
to sit, to stay, to linger,
to talk, to think, to have
a meeting.
And so they have taken
an old space, the Yard,
a beautiful, iconic
space, and remade it
in a way that is both
respectful of its past
and embodies the
spirit of the present
and some important uses for
the creation of connections
and interactions among our
students, faculty, staff,
and friends.